this is an awesome uh what we call this
pantsuit
i think it's like a really standard
pantsuit yeah
so it's awesome i dig it
what are your responsibilities here
today as the uh
as the was the chairperson
i i think my title is honorary chair
for the independent spirit awards this
is the first time i've ever been to the
independent spirit awards
and so i uh i feel very very lucky i
love independent movies i have made them
my whole life so i uh it's a it's
actually a true true honor to be here
congratulations on the oscar nomination
what is that
that must mean
so much to you
i am
truly astounded and
unbelievably
moved and touched and like just stunned
i love this movie i i just uh saw the
director of spencer for the first time
since we found out about the nomination
and um just seeing the look on his face
and all of the work that we put into
this like just evident in his smile made
me so happy
i know like award season can kind of be
a little bit of a roller coaster was
there any point in your mind where
you're like
if it doesn't happen that's that's fine
i'm okay with that like i don't need an
oscar nomination to be a
a happy person
of course yeah i think uh throughout
like from the beginning throughout and
up until the end i felt that way
um even just being
the fact that anyone would have ever
even uttered the words she was
like i've never even gotten
i've never even gotten kind of close so
this
this experience alone even without the
nomination would have been really
stunning final question in a different
gear um you had said at one point that
you wanted guy fieri to uh officiate
your wedding we spoke to him he said
he's down
what an invite and i am so down and
kristen i'm waiting for you to call me
and tell me about this where we're doing
this and how we're doing this would you
be interested in having him cook for
your wedding as well
yeah of course what would you want him
to make
um
i don't know i just whatever he wants
that's his deal you know i think
i heard that he officiates like gay
weddings because his sister is is queer
and she was like i don't know i just
heard that story and i was like who
i i might be able to actually swing that
like i could probably get in contact
with this guy
um and apparently yeah i'm there i just
need to plan everything first